meanwhile Gary where did you guys go
here in Miami where Sal was using his
broken English oh man so Sal we went to
a Cuban restaurant right we decided
we're going to have a full experience so
like all of us went to this Cuban
restaurant here let me play you some
tape so [__] embarrassing Sal who is
sexually frustrated even though he's
married you know what I mean it's like
Sal gets to the restaurant and there's a
lovely waitress there she was an older
nice woman she's very nice very nice and
Sal starts flirting on her feet all day
yeah exactly and Robin maybe maybe she
could use a laugh maybe a Charming
customer instead of a mean customer it's
a crowded restaurant she got 50 [__]
people to take care of and then she's
like got the nud neck who's flirting
with her here he goes here's Sal
flirting with the Cuban waitress and
then proposes in Spanish
yes of course
I've just found the love of my life here
tonight Janet I would like to say
something how do you say marry me in
Spanish
foreign
I was sitting directly across from the
south so I got a first-hand look at his
charm and pouring it on when she would
come over everything thank you
sweetheart I'm not a mean question very
nice sweetheart you don't call a woman
I'll stop it already that's a go-to word
he does it all the time and honey
constant sweetheart and then he has this
move where he's like I can speak fluent
Spanish and we're like okay and you
heard but what he does is he speaks
Italian right and he throws Spanish
words same thing no it's not the same
thing literally not the same thing oh my
God you're such an embarrassment
I had and I am a waffle see
poor woman could have been done with the
taking their order she's now she's got
Mr Personality at the table okay
Janet she's my plus one at your wedding
Ronnie
poor woman
at the table now an hour yeah and it
didn't stop there so Sam was so smitten
he stood up in the middle of the
restaurant and started singing to the
waitress
yeah I know hold on to your hat I'm
getting divorceo El otornio
so
no more rifle no more no more
thank you thank you what a song that
needs music
[Music]